Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di
Cucina Buttata, un pochino di tempo fa
abbiamo provato la carbonara francese,
abbiamo preso un piatto italiano e abbiamo
visto come lo facevano e come lo
distruggevano all'estero. Sono arrivati
tanti commenti alcuni divertiti, altri di
odio motivato, altri anche un po' meno
ragazzi. E alla fine ci siamo detti "Sì ok,
noi siamo romani, forse prima di provare
la carbonara francese avremmo dovuto
spiegare come si fa La Carbonara
Ora partiamo dal presupposto che esistono un
sacco di varianti, credo che questa
versione non l'ho mai fatta in vita mia,
ci sono un sacco di questi: pancetta
guanciale, cipolla, non cipolla, quante
uova, l'albume si l'albume no
E' arrivato il momento di spiegare come
viene fatta, senza giudizio ragazzi
perché calcolate che mia madre la fa col
prezzemolo, ed è buonissima ma non è una
carbonara. Per fare La Carbonara avrete
bisogno di ah no abbiamo già sbagliato la pasta
Tonnarelli o rigatoni a seconda di
pasta lunga o pasta corta ma noi non abbiamo
trovato né i tonarelli né i rigatoni quindi
abbiamo, che figura di m***a, Papi, gli spaghetti alla
chitarra. Vabbè gli spaghetti alla
chitarra perché sono un pochino grossi
un po' corposini, una pasta all'uovo. Oh riga
cioè...Uova, pecorino. Il pecorino migliore
sarebbe teoricamente quello nero, quello
romano, noi abbiamo trovato quello di
amatrice, che comunque "me coglioni".
Guanciale, non pancetta, non bacon, non
quella...panciuale, guanciale sacopo' soprattutto, guanciale amatriciana. Guanciale amatriciana?
Ma stiamo a fa l'amatriciana noi? Vabbè ok, e
infine pepe nero. In alcuni ristoranti
dove sono stato, specialmente a milano, la
carbonara a volte la servono con uovo
pancetta e senza pepe - Cioè te ti sei preso la carbonara a Milano? (Gianmarco)
- Non io, l'ho vista mangiare, ti pare che mi prendo la
car...A Milano una cosa buonissima è
l'orecchio d'elefante. Comunque non stiamo
parlando di quello. Ragazzi è
importantissimo, la carbonara si chiama Di cosa state parlando?...Dumbo? - L'elefante...eh (Gianmarco)
- Ma non è un orecchio di elefante.
Ma tu pensavi che fosse un orecchio...
L'orecchia d'elefante è la cotolettona
che si chiama orecchia d'elefante perché è
larga quanto un'orecchia d'elefante - Ma questo è un c*****e! (Enrico) - Perché a Milano mangiano orecchie di
elefanti. Ma questo è un c****e! - Cioè è una cotoletta quindi? (Gianmarco) -
- Non è una cotoletta, è come di una pasta con l'uovo
Se avete dei commenti di odio non per me
ma per Gianmarco. Pepe nero ragazzi, è
fondamentale mettere il pepe nero
all'interno della carbonara, altrimenti
perché dovrebbe chiamarsi carbonara?
Carbone perché la riempì di pepe nero
così tanto che sembra quasi carbonizzata, ora
io magari esagero
- Ma secondo me non si chiama carbonara per questo (Enrico) - Certo - Perché la
mangiavano i carbonari - si? Eh si Guglielmo (Enrico) - ...Io mi informerei prima di dire queste c*****e
forse ho detto una
cazzata io...forse - Beh Gu è più plausibile la mia che la tua
- Vabbé andiamo avanti, metteteci il pepe. Io nel frattempo ho già
messo l'acqua sul fuoco perché in realtà
la carbonare è una pasta veramente veloce
Cosa importante è il sale nell'acqua, non
mettetegliene troppo perché dal momento che
abbiamo il guanciale e il pecorino già
sarà abbastanza salata e poi soprattutto
nel momento in cui utilizzeremo l'acqua
di cottura per fare la cremina rischiamo
veramente che ci partano i reni. Incominciamo, mettiamone...Oddio! - ...Gu non esagerare
cioè nel senso ne hai messo un quintale (Enrico) - Non è vero, hai già mentito. Tu finirai
all'inferno. Partiamo subito con il guanciale
Lo tiriamo fuori - Stai attento (Gianmarco) - Attento a cosa mi morde?
- Prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è eliminare la cotenna
Tipo il nostro amico Chef Barbato la utilizza
per soffriggerla insieme al guanciale
Lo facciamo? - Non puoi essere criticato per una cosa del genere (Gianmarco)
- No ma poi Chef Barbato non lo criticherei mai, il nostro collega - Il grembiule - Ah cacchio il grembiule
- Non ce la facciamo mai - Non è possibile ragazzi (Enrico) - Non ce la facciamo mai
Come lo posso indossare in maniera divertente? - Sorridendo (Enrico)
Una cosa importantissima quando si
taglia il guanciale è il verso in cui lo
si affetta. Ma non ne stiamo mettendo troppo?
Vabbè che il guanciale non è mai troppo. E poi
bisogna tagliarlo in questo senso,
vedete? Le listarelle devono essere così
- Ma se ne metti uno sopra l'altro? (Enrico)
- Si vabbè volevo farlo vedere
- Certo potevi metterne più di due (Enrico) - Sono tre - Hai levato la cotenna da tutto? (Gianmarco)
Si, tranne quella sopra che in realtà sono spezie
- Occhio (Gianmarco) - Chef Barbato lo usa...Mamma mia non ti convince (Gianmarco) - Allora voi la
tenente la parte nera oppure no? Oddio
stiamo già iniziando con questo? Siamo
già arrivati a questo punto? Calcolate
che mia madre la fa con la pancetta, le
uova intere, prezzemolo, ma con molto amore - La cipolla (Enrico) - La cipolla - La cipolla è vero. Cioè sto
parlando con umiltà comunque ragazzi, non è
che vi sto dicendo "Siete degli sfigati
se non la fate così". Vai stiamo
accendendo la cappa. Cotenne
sul fuoco. Allora la pancetta ne stiamo usando
un botto - Non è pancetta Guglielmo (Enrico)
Niente olio spero (Gianmarco)
No niente olio. Mi madre ci mette pure
l'olio...Mentre nel frattempo il guanciale
sfrigola prendiamo il pecorino - Deve essere croccante il guanciale (Enrico)
- Ti preferivo sai quando? Quando non c'eri
L'ho tagliato un po grandino, forse avrei
dovuto farlo ancora più sottile però
così se facciamo proprio il morsone. La
sto facendo male. Allora posso dirvi solo una
cosa? Secondo me all'inferno c'è un
girone dove devono fare questo tutto il
tempo. Secondo me è una tortura...Nel frattempo
passiamo alla questione uova.
Ci sono varie scuole di pensiero
Noi stiamo per mettere 500 grammi di pasta,
siamo in tre, si dice un uovo più un
uovo a testa. Siamo tre, io metto un tuorlo ogni cento
Solo i tuorli - C'è anche chi la fa con l'albume no? (Gianmarco) - C'è anche chi la fa con l'albume
- Che forse è quella più...(Gianmarco) - Che forse è quella più...
Prendiamo le uova, le sbattiamo un pochino.
Mamma mia quanto so daltonico mi
sembrano verdi alcuni pezzi.
A me sembra verde a te sembra verde
Aggiungiamo il pecorino e ora dovremo
creare una pasta. Mettiamo la pasta
Dillo alla camera di non spezzarli (Gianmarco) - Non spezzateli. Il guanciale diventerà
croccantissimo e come vedete non serve
l'olio. Oggi voglio fa il fico, voglio far
vedere che non sono semplicemente una
bomba sexy messa davanti a dei fornelli
non dovrebbe aver paura se è pastosino
perché è normale, ve l'allungate con
l'acqua di cottura che non dovete
buttare, è sempre un po' un sacro graal
prezioso. Molte persone pensano che
diluisca ma in realtà il glutine
presente all'interno della pasta aiuta a
creare la cremina, quindi se siete
fondamentalmente
...Se siete celiaci
la pasta ce l'avete sempre un po'
allungata credo, non so magari è na cazzata
che dico. Ne avrò dette poche. Prendiamo il pepe
intanto mentre Enrico cerca il piatto, ne mettiamo un po' dentro già al intingolo - Guglielmo non ci stanno
- Dei piatti non ci sono? Ragazzi non sono pazzo - E' pazzo!
- Mazza questo c'ha davvero tre piatti - Si, come fai a vive con tre piatti Pierfra?
Ma ragazzi prendiamo altri due piatti e così c'avete già il vostro piatto fatto - Valli a trovà (Enrico)
Cioè stiamo cercando piatti di qualsiasi...Ok
abbiamo l'altro piatto di Enrico non
Non va bene questo? Quello nero ok.
Prendiamo acqua di cottura e la
versiamo qua dentro...Ne ho messa troppa, troppo
liquido ragazzi una rosa buona
Una cosa buona dell'acqua di cottura, non cuoce l'uovo
ma lo pastorizza
- L'acqua la pasta (Enrico) - Sto sbagliando tutto!
Spegniamo il fuoco e aggiungiamo l'uovo
Si -Si -Si - Si - Si - Siii- Siii
- Vi farò due impiattamenti, per quello
chic avremmo bisogno di un coppapasta - Sei un gourmet, GUrmet (Enrico)
Rega, gourmet al ca... La carbonara riposata fa cagare.
Vi prego possiamo azzittire sto coso?
Era lui che mi sta mettendo l'ansia. Spruzzata di
pecorino messa sopra, pepe...ualà...Velocemente
vi faccio vedere invece un impiattamento alla romana, non richiede un
coppapasta, richiede semplicemente molta fretta
Eccolo qui, puoi fare un...aiutarmi. L'impiattamento alla
romana poi mentre una persona cerca di
già strapparvi il piatto, con una mano le
dovete tenere il polso
"Aspetta un secondo" e in quei pochi
secondi in cui lui avvicinerà il piatto
alla sua cosa dovete velocemente crearglielo tutto quanto prima che lui prenda
il piatto per sé. Infine abbiamo l'impiattamento alla
Enrico, è un pochino più complicato.
Praticamente tu hai, allora aspetta un
secondo...ci sta, nono è giusto.
Quindi questo qui possiamo darlo al
gatto e questo qui è di Enrico, e direi che è
arrivato il momento di assaggiare - Erlè spruzzata di
pecorino? - Gradirei però un impiattamento alla romana, sto per portare il piatto alla bocca - Vai
Allora aspetta un secondo, aspetta un secondo, veloce veloce - Io sto provando - Ottimo vedi ti ho messo quella
roba per... - Esatto - Facciamo l'assaggio
- Buonissima si...Una Carbonara... - Mamma mia!
- Ragazzi miei - ...E' divina! Ragazzi noi stiamo morendo di fame
finiremo questi piatti che saranno pure il
nostro pranzo. Come sempre taggatemi su
Instagram se cercherete di fare anche
voi la carbonara diciamo nella maniera
più originale possibile. Fatemi sapere
qua sotto in realtà se siete romani e
conoscete magari delle varianti
ufficiali o se non siete romani e
conoscete delle varianti non ufficiali ma
che comunque sono buone. Che dire noi ci
vediamo sempre la prossima domenica a
mezzogiorno. Ciao
Comunque posso dire la cosa gourmet chi se la i****a!